hi there
think about those really great holiday
hits you keep hearing during the
holidays if you could get all those
special songs on one special album
wouldn't that be special that would be
something worth playing over and over
and over again and again that album is
iJustine and studio eights Christmas
caroling wonderland and we do the ring
ding ding ding ding ding ding-a-ling -
and yes those ring ding ding
nah jingle bell jingle bell jingle I'll
take a jingle bells and jingle bells
jingle bell jingle bell jingle indeed
that's the deep of LG one foggy
Christmas Eve santa came to say it's a
foggy Christmas Eve so I came to say and
then one foggy Christmas Eve santa came
to say
here comes Santa Claus here comes Santa
Claus here comes Santa Claus here comes
Santa Claus here comes Santa Claus hark
the herald angels sing hark the herald
angels sing hark the herald angels sing
hark the herald angels sing' in field
field field on the twelfth day of
christmas my true love gave to me twelve
golden rings eleven golden rings nine
golden rings a golden ring seven golden
rings six golden rings five golden rings
four golden rings three golden rings two
golden rings and a ring that was really
gone this is the finest album you'll
ever find but remember you can't find it
in any stores on television or on the
internet the only place you can get it
it's right here order now
you